he knew that he was not going to be
offered a title Eliminator unless it was
in a circumstance like this on short
notice right he had to take the Gilbert
Burns fight he took it he went a little
bit too full throttle injured his ankle
thought through all of that and just as
mentally forged as Gilbert Burns or
anybody else will allow knew that he had
to take this fight to to set up a title
fight and yeah he'll sit for 18 months
if he has to but lost one of those guys
guys are like you know there's nothing
that stands out on this guy there's
nothing that Wows you but man he was how
to put it all together what's really
interesting about Bilal he's also kind
of a chameleon in that he can beat you
in a lot of different ways he may not be
that crazy finisher he knows how to win
rounds and he can do it in a variety of
ways and I think that's what makes him
such a tough out for a lot of people